the state of apple gaming has been
suffering for years now but it looks
like all of that is about to change
because apple is about to totally
disrupt the entire gaming industry yes
that's right we just got a mind-blowing
report from puck saying that apple is
reportedly talking with electronic arts
about a potential acquisition yes they
could be buying out ea games one of the
biggest aaa gaming developer studios out
there so in this video i'm going to
answer a very important question what if
apple buys out ea games what's it going
to look like what kind of games are
going to be where which games are gonna
have native apple silicon support which
games are gonna end up on apple arcade
and which games are gonna stay the same
just as we like them i'm gonna answer
all of that and i'm also gonna talk
about apple's history with gaming and
apple arcade and how everything is right
now so let's get started by jumping into
this report apparently ea games has
spoken to several potential suitors
including apple amazon and disney as it
looks for a merger arrangement now
disney was the first pick but it ended
up not working out and disney decided
not to pursue a purchase now ea also
spoke with nbc universal and was close
to a deal but it didn't work out which
makes it more and more likely that apple
could actually be the one that buys out
ea games because they definitely have
enough money to do it they have a ton of
cash and it would probably benefit apple
the most out of anybody out there and
that's mainly because an ea acquisition
would give apple access to a number of
highly popular gaming franchises which
is probably the number one thing that's
missing from apple systems right now so
i was going through the comments on mac
rumors and people made some very
interesting points like first of all the
sims being an apple ip would be huge
imagine apple owns all of the sims they
would be able to take those games put
them on apple platforms and then
continue to create better and better
sims games that people are gonna love
because the sims is huge but even better
this commenter mentioned that ea sports
will bring a lot of attention for
apple's incoming ar vr headset yes we've
been hearing a lot of those leaks and
we've recently been getting more and
more rumors like this one for example
saying that apple's ar vr headset is
nearing completion as the board the
apple board gets a demo yes this is how
close we are to apple's vr headset being
ready they're actually showing demos to
the board members on apple which is
incredible and we recently got another
leak saying that apple's headset is
going to be featuring 14 cameras which
is mind-blowing enabling lifelike
avatars which is basically memojis which
apple has really been pushing into and
now check this out i'm looking at the
website for ea sports which is just a
small part of ea games and by the way
i'm going to be going through all of the
different studios that ea games owns
later on in this video and just showing
you guys how big of a purchase this
would be for apple but just looking at
ea sports look at this we got f1 racing
we got madden nfl football we got fifa
soccer we have hockey nhl ufc we have
golf all of these titles that are huge
could be owned by apple which is going
to be such a huge deal for them
especially because just a couple of
months ago at apple's march 8th event
apple announced that you're gonna have
friday night football yes mlb games
shown weekly on apple tv plus yeah
they're gonna be streamed live but
before i start covering all of the other
studios that are owned by ea because
this is a huge list i actually have to
talk about the current state of apple
gaming with apple arcade yes it's a five
dollar a month service which is actually
a good deal because you're getting
access to over 200 games and you're not
having any issues with ads inside of the
games or in-game purchases and another
reason i think it makes so much sense
for apple to really push apple arcade as
much as they can potentially with an ea
games buyout is because apple arcade is
part of their apple one service which i
recently subscribed to where you can pay
20 or 30 bucks a month and get
everything included you can get icloud
apple news fitness apple arcade apple tv
plus and apple music for the whole
family everything for 30 bucks a month
which is actually saving a lot of money
compared to if you just bought
everything yourself and the cool thing
is that apple has continued adding newer
and better games to apple arcade like
disney melee mania which i've played and
i actually quite enjoy and based on some
of the reviews including max in our
office and this person on reddit they
said they have a family of four so it's
worth it you only have one membership
fee and no requests for micro
transactions from my kids so that is a
big deal because there are some people
that are getting charged on their credit
cards for their kids playing games and
buying stuff without them knowing so
with apple arcade you don't have to
worry about that but on the other hand
there is one huge flaw with apple arcade
there are a lot of people that are
complaining that they're just mainly
remastered games mobile games nothing
that's really engaging and no
aaa titles and i think that's one thing
that a lot of people are frustrated with
since apple arcade doesn't really have
aaa games like this reddit poster
pointed out why isn't apple paying big
money to two to three big game studios
in order to create at least one to two
big aaa games that will put apple arcade
in the map of the gaming industry and
attract a lot of new people yes that is
exactly what i think apple could be
doing by potentially buying out ea games
and the awesome thing about that is that
we actually did get some leaks and
rumors especially from stella fudge
saying that apple arcade is getting big
money poured into it there are currently
titles in the works that are aiming to
rival the likes of breath of the wild
which is a big deal if you didn't
already know games like this take years
to make so maybe apple has been working
on some awesome aaa games for a while
and we just haven't seen them get
released yet and making it even better
earlier this month we actually got some
new leaks that apple is reportedly
negotiating with ubisoft to secure
exclusive titles for a hybrid game
console well first of all of course is
going to come to apple arcade but
apparently they might be creating an
apple gaming console to challenge the
nintendo switch so it could be handheld
just like the switch but in my opinion i
think that all of that is pointing to a
new gaming controller yes an apple
gaming controller that could look like
this because this is an official apple
patent and as you can see you have an
iphone in the middle and these two
controllers on the side that connect to
it which is basically like the backbone
one mobile controller where you stick
your iphone in the middle it plugs into
lighting and you basically have hardware
controls with low latency and based on
all the reviews a lot of people are
enjoying the gaming controllers that are
built like that because it's just so
convenient to play and the reason i
think it makes the most sense for apple
to create a gaming controller for the
iphone is because we just got this
report about the 2022 gaming spotlight
with mobile gaming extending its lead
over pc and console gaming and check out
this incredible chart this right here is
worldwide consumer spending on games for
mobile gaming it is skyrocketing above
pc and mac gaming above home consoles
and above handheld consoles and if
you're struggling to understand why
mobile gaming is doing so much better
than all the other platforms well
appletree on twitter made a very good
point gpu costs are astronomical yes if
you're going to be playing on a mac or a
console you got to spend a lot of money
compared to a lot of mobile games just
working on your current iphone or
android but getting back to the original
article about apple talking with ea
games about a potential purchase i want
to be real with you guys and let you
know that if this does happen it could
take some time for those games to come
to apple devices like for example those
aaa games like potentially battlefield
being ported over and optimized with
native apple silicon support which is
going to be a huge deal for mac gaming
and then of course some of the other
games coming down to apple arcade but
with that said let's finally get into
the part of the video where i talk about
which games apple would actually be
acquiring if it purchases
ea games first up we have bioware which
is in charge of anthem mass effect
dragon age and star wars the old
republic then moving on we have chilingo
which has a bunch of these mobile games
that are currently on the ios app store
what apple would do is some of them
they'd probably pawn on apple arcade but
some of the others they might leave the
same and just take advantage of those
profits from those micro transactions
and then moving on we have code masters
which is actually in charge of grid f1
and dirt dirt 5 and all the other games
and keep in mind they make games for all
of the console so apple would be taking
in all those profits for themselves and
they would be deciding which of these
games they would be putting on apple
platforms then we have criterion which
was doing work on a need for speed it
was doing work on battlefield on star
wars burnouts all of these other games
we also have dice dice works on
battlefield and this i think is going to
be the biggest deal because this game
franchise alone being on apple silicon
max would totally change the state of
apple gaming and not only that look at
these older games that dice created that
apple would basically take ownership of
and then we have capital games making
star wars galaxy of heroes they've got
fire monkeys studios with real racing 3
the sims mobile which is going to be
huge this sims free play need for speed
no limits and then of course we have
frostbite which is an absolutely huge
deal because apple would basically own
their latest frostbite engine which is
an incredible engine that's being put
into use into a lot of the new games
then on top of that we have industrial
toys which is currently in charge of
helping out create battlefield mobile
which i think is going to be a huge
mobile game owning the sims ip would be
huge for the future of apple gaming we
also have metalhead which looks like it
makes some of the baseball games we have
motive which looks like created dead
space in some of the games like star
wars squadrons and battlefront 2. we
have playdemk which is working on making
new mobile games including golf clash of
course we have pogo which has a ton of
online browser games and then this is a
huge one because they have pop cap games
which is creating a lot of these games
like plants versus zombies bejeweled and
all these little games that are making a
ton of money on the app store right now
not only that but we have respawn
entertainment which worked on apex
legends especially the new mobile game
that just came out which is awesome star
wars jedi fallen order and medal of
honor titanfall as well then of course
we have ripple effect studios which are
helping out with the battlefield games
and then finally once again we have ea
sports which could be by far the biggest
deal for apple because they just sell so
many copies of the games for consoles
and apple could just do so much in the
future with ea sports so now that we're
looking at this huge list of studios
that are owned by ea games apple could
potentially be the biggest
game studio in the world and the biggest
deal that i want to point out is that
even if apple ends up not purchasing ea
games this article proves that apple is
at least speaking to huge
aaa game developers about potentially
buying them out so it kind of shows
where apple's focus is right now and it
shows how much money apple is willing to
potentially spend to push apple gaming
forward and i think that's a very good
sign because if this deal doesn't work
they could potentially be targeting
other game developers and studios now if
you totally disagree or you have a bunch
of doubts let me know down in the
comment section below but if you enjoy
this video and you're hoping for some
awesome apple games coming soon then
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you